the 7th of October 2022 was a big day
for all Tesla fans because Elon went on
Twitter to announce the new Tesla semi
truck to be finally released later this
year this all-electric battery-powered
Class 8 semi truck is an incredible
vehicle and in this video I will tell
you all the reasons you have to look
forward to its release origin Elon first
talked about the Tesla semi in his
master plan part dur in 2016 and his
original aim with this vehicle was to
cover the primary forms of terrestrial
transport he believed that heavy duty
trucks and high passenger density Urban
transport were the need of the hour and
he wanted to go further than sedans in
SUVs he also claimed that the Tesla semi
would substantially reduce cargo
transport costs while improving safety
and making operating more fun fast
forward to November 2017 and the semi
was finally unveiled to the public Elon
initially compared the vehicle to semi
trucks on the road and at 2 million US
dollar Supercar the Bugatti Chiron but
the one domain where the truck was
testing to stand out was its performance
four independent Motors were originally
planned to be incorporated into the semi
however the number was later reduced to
three but make no mistake about its
functionality because the vehicle didn't
slow down by any means in fact right
after its announcement Elon demonstrated
how the Tesla semi reaches 60 miles per
hour in 5 seconds without a load isn't
that awesome as remarkable as its engine
is it's not just the functionality of
the semi truck that makes it a promising
vehicle in addition the exterior design
is just as incredible so let's have a
look design although the official launch
of the Tesla semi truck was originally
set for 2019 it got delayed and ended up
being way behind schedule now we're
finally going to witness the
long-awaited electric truck that will
begin its deliveries on the 1st of
December 2022 to PepsiCo the news was
confirmed by the food and beverage giant
claiming that the trucks will be used at
two different facilities in California
the semi features a tri-motor Powertrain
that produces instant torque and
unparalleled power at any speed allowing
drivers to merge safely while keeping up
with traffic also according to Tesla
charging with electricity is
approximately 2.5 times cheaper per mile
than refueling with diesel do you know
what that means for the company they'll
save up to 200 000 US Dollars within the
first three years not only that but the
semi will also minimize downtime because
it can charge up to 70 percent in as
little as 30 minutes the fans have also
noticed Tesla updating their semi-press
Gallery which means the release is
definitely happening even though there
have been a lot of changes from the
version Elon showed us in 2017 you can
still recognize the semi-truck from a
mile away the massive mirrors and a
slightly revised Greenhouse are the most
distinctive features along with new door
handles black trim at the back of the
cab and exposed rear wheels as for the
interior of the semi truck it's evident
the engineers went the extra mile to
make it unique and exciting it's been
revamped to appear more production ready
with a new console and a steering wheel
featuring controls a few modifications
have been made to the original dashboard
too and the new version seems to have a
tiered design now I must remind you here
that fans initially hesitated to believe
the semi truck was actually happening
because of the delay we've seen in its
launch nevertheless I'm hopeful we'll
get to see the actual vehicle this time
and Elon wasn't just trolling with his
tweet next up let us dive a little
deeper into the features that make the
new Tesla semi unlike any other vehicle
on the market features and pricing Tesla
says the semi will offer approximately
300 and 500 Mile ranges with active
safety features that ensure traction and
stability in all conditions and terrains
the truck's very characteristic Central
seating position gives the driver a new
outlook and better visibility reducing
the possibility of accidents added to
the unique seating arrangement is an
all-electric architecture that reduces
rollover risk and cabin intrusion so
yeah the engineers took the safety
aspect pretty seriously for a vehicle
this Advanced it's unsurprising that the
truck will start at an expected base
price of a hundred and fifty thousand US
dollars for a 300 mile range battery and
a hundred and eighty thousand US dollars
for a 500 mile range the first 1000
semis however will be considered the
founders series and start at 200 000 US
Dollars oh and if you want to make
reservations for the truck to be in the
elite Founders that would be an added
twenty thousand dollars so is the price
tag worth it the design and the features
of the Tesla semi truck are indeed
exceptional but what exactly is mosh
trying to achieve in the long run given
the company's track record it must have
a vision and specific problems to solve
Tesla's Vision big rigs with trailers
face safety concerns that are unlike
those experienced by other vehicles one
such problem is jackknifing and the new
Tesla semi truck might just solve the
issue once and for all for those that
might not know exactly jackknifing is
what happens when a truck cab violently
turns one way but the trailer goes
another the result is pretty unfortunate
an imbalance resulting in the truck
flipping on one side and cutting a
devastating path across Highway Lanes
the Tesla semi has active safety
measures that seem to be designed to
prevent jackknifing in particular it
does so by taking advantage of its
electric drivetrain which includes
independent motors for each wheel when
the truck senses an unequal weight
distribution across its Wheels the
motors are actuated accordingly to
optimize traction control this in turn
automatically corrects for mishaps like
oversteering in response to weight
shifts so in essence the semi will do
anything in its power to prevent a
jackknifing accident without needing
external driver intervention according
to musk jackknifing is impossible with
the Tesla semi truck that's a bold claim
but it offers drivers additional Peace
of Mind knowing that their vehicle has
an extra layer of safety in fact it even
assures logistics companies that their
investment and Personnel are protected
the combination of advanced safety
features improve reliability and
Superior performance make the Tesla semi
One of a Kind it can potentially improve
delivery timelines for drivers by
enhancing The Experience on the road
with minimal delays drivers would be
able to consistently reach their
destination on schedule delivering Goods
to clients on time and Paving the way
for better profit margins another reason
the electric powered Tesla semi truck
would be an appealing option for Fleet
managers is the increased sustainability
and reduced fuel costs the emphasis on
sustainable business practices in recent
years has compelled organizations
worldwide to explore newer ways to
improve their systems the transition of
businesses in the logistics and shipping
sector away from fossil fuels is part of
these efforts and the introduction of
the Tesla semi truck in the market will
accelerate the process now that the need
for long-haul semi trucks is evident
primarily because of the demand by Major
shippers and freight companies the
future of this class of vehicles
switching entirely to Electric is
inevitable the introduction of Tesla's
semi is the first step towards that goal
but there's still a long way to go
before we're fully ready to make the
shift from oil and fossil fuels to
electric power the future of EV semis if
we're looking to decarbonize our
transportation system system entirely
it's unwise to neglect semi trucks
because electrifying this category of
vehicles is a fundamental part of the
future that the likes of Elon Musk
Envision but the good news is that
companies are investing in electric semi
trucks not for political or aesthetic
reasons but because the total cost of
ownership favors them the daily driving
chores of a semi truck are much more
predictable than a passenger car which
means charging infrastructure can be
tailored to the precise needs of the
truck most charging will occur at a
freight terminal every night while the
trucks are parked instead of using
public charging equipment like in the
case of electric cars and not to mention
the drastically reduced carbon emissions
Fleet managers collectively agree that
going electric is the smartest and most
economical choice so yeah even though
we're used to seeing a shiny new
electric car or SUV debut every other
week semi-trucks might be undergoing an
electric Revolution much faster than
most of us are paying attention to well
that's it from my end if you enjoyed
watching this video don't forget to hit
the Subscribe button also if you're in
interested in learning more about
electric vehicles check out the other
videos on the cards thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time